our main story tonight concerns the US
Postal Service the organization that
would have delivered your Mother's Day
card for today
if you hadn't forgotten to mail one like
an ungrateful sack of the USPS
provides valuable services from
delivering mail and packages to
brilliantly ruining tip-top videos that
is excellent from the wave to the laughs
to the how you doing every single part
of that is great I want that woman to
interrupt every tick-tock video in fact
take this one of an orange cat involved
in it interspecies orgy already very
good right exactly hard to improve upon
but watch this it's just instantly
better that's a cake on a cake right
there keep crushing tic TOCs you
national treasure the Postal
Service has a rich and storied history
actually predates the founding of this
country and it has an obligation to
bring mail to every single household
even transporting it to the bottom of
the Grand Canyon by MU over the years
Americans have relied on it for a
surprisingly wide variety of needs
country children often watch for the
mailman just see what has come today a
big box with many holes in it the box is
full of baby chicks baby chicks don't
have to eat or drink for a whole day
after they're hatched so they can travel
safely through the mail it's true you
used to be able to send live baby chicks
through the mail and guess what you
still can the Postal Service will
transport all kinds of live poultry for
you including chickens ducks and geese
and turkeys which actually raises the
question why the would I ever send
a greeting card again when I could mail
someone a birthday turkey or a thank-you
doc or a sympathy goose who wouldn't
want a sympathy goose I mean sure your
Nana's dead but now you have a small
goose which is and this is true better
but the current pandemic is obviously
making things very difficult for postal
workers right now as you probably know
from seeing stories like these I am very
worried very worried where I mean to the
point that I worry about coming to work
every day I don't want to contract to
bring it back to my family do you feel
like you're at risk every time you go to
work yes
and say that it's not in the back of
everybody's mind there is a joke amongst
the office are we essential or
sacrificial holy that is a dark
joke most office humor is just on the
level of working hard or hardly working
or someone's microwaving fish again not
will any of us die today LMFAO and those
fears are not misplaced
over a thousand postal workers have
tested positive for Kovac 19 and more
than 40 have died for both in addition
to and because of the ongoing pandemic
these workers are also having to grapple
with another existential threat the
postal service may be about to go broke
the outgoing Postmaster General recently
asked Congress for a total of 89 billion
dollars and without financial help the
USPS may not make it past September
without significant service
interruptions which is upsetting
especially during an election year a
census year and a pandemic that has
people housebound and I know people do
love to complain about the post office
but the truth is it does very important
work and many people really rely on it
not just to receive packages but in
rural areas in particular a post office
can be a community hub that brings
people together just listen to this
postmaster in rural Colorado tell a
heartwarming story with a bit of a twist
postmaster burger says neighbors who
live far apart run into each other at
the post office that's how everybody
keeps in touch including him it's
provided me the opportunity to to know
these people in this town more than I
ever thought I would know even a degree
where sometimes on my lunch hour I find
myself helping a neighbor Barry's dog
okay first what second excuse me it's
just a circle back the also you
just said sometimes you help bury a dog
that's plural meaning you've done it
more than once
helping someone do that once is a
courtesy but when it starts becoming a
regular thing you have to wonder why the
neighborhood dogs keep dying and why
you're always there the point is at the
worst possible time this American
institution is on the brink of collapse
so tonight we thought it might be worth
asking why that is and what can be done
about it and let's start with the fact
that despite being part of the federal
government the postal service is
actually a self-funded entity it
operates independently and is meant to
pay for itself with the money that it
makes from services and postage that
might help explain why over the years
it's often tried to encourage stamp
collecting with commercials like this
[Music]
first that song can get it and also to
dos on featuring all the stamps that
kids love from those slamming dino
stamps to the dank get well stamped with
irises - my personal favorite the one
that simply says lace-making
and I think I speak for cool kids
everywhere and I say there's simply
nothing doper than a totally bitchin
laced stamp I'm just worried it might be
too cool and you might think that you
know why the Postal Service is in so
much trouble
that the internet and email mean that
people just don't use it as much but
that's not actually the main reason in
fact experts believe it would still be
turning a profit we're not for a 2006
law called the postal accountability and
Enhancement Act now one of the things
that it required was for the USPS to
prepay healthcare benefits for retirees
on a 50-year schedule starting with an
aggressive obligation to set aside over
five billion dollars a year for 10 years
that in itself was a massive burden to
put on the Postal Service but the law
also limited its flexibility to raise
money by putting price caps on major
products like first-class mail so they
had massive new obligations to meet even
as their income was basically locked in
place now in hindsight he seems like a
pretty clear death Center Twitter
makes it so strange that it passed
largely unnoticed at the time and with
bipartisan support and the effect was
almost immediate because the Postal
Service went from reporting a net income
of 900 million dollars in 2006 to a loss
of 3.8 billion just three years later
and good luck selling enough dope-ass
lace stamps to get yourself out of that
hole so the truth is the Postal
Service's problems aren't entirely from
the fact that we started using email or
even the 2008 recession in fact it's
been estimated that the stipulations of
this one law have accounted for
approximately 74 percent of their net
losses since it passed and that is
despite them shedding over a hundred
thousand jobs and the fact they were so
badly hobbled by an act of Congress
makes it a little infuriating that some
like former Fox News commentator John
Stossel hold it up as a sign that
government agencies are just naturally
bloated and incompetent another myth
government can run the post office like
a business but real businesses can't
lose billions every year 16 billion last
year FedEx UPS and others make billions
because they innovate and cut costs okay
there's a lot wrong with that but he is
right that FedEx is pretty good at
innovating for example you've probably
seen the arrow hidden in the FedEx logo
but did you know that for years they're
also used to be a swastika hidden in the
D yeah
once you see it like the arrow you can't
unsee it but they took it out because
businesses have to innovate
now what's docile is advocating for
their and what many conservatives would
prefer is for the postal service to be
privatized but there are some huge
drawbacks to that idea for starters as
you may have noticed FedEx and UPS
charged are of a lot more to
deliver than the Postal Service does
also those remote addresses that they
are obligated to deliver to aren't just
difficult to get to they're not
profitable and in all likelihood
companies would cut those routes off
meaning a lot of people would lose
access and to his credit john stossel
fully acknowledges that although
basically says in response tough
the Constitution says Congress has the
power to establish post offices it
doesn't have to and it doesn't have to
do
liver mail to all of America who says
there needs to be universal service if I
live way out in the boondocks I could
get email now it's hard to decide what I
like least about that his dismissive
attitude towards rural Americans the
incorrect assumption that email is a
decent substitute for the postal service
conveniently glossing over the fact that
an estimated 42 million people lack
access to broadband internet or the
unfortunate fact that john stossel looks
like what would happen if someone tried
to queer I Geraldo Rivera but it didn't
really work and again
the postal service is a literal lifeline
for many Americans it reportedly
delivered 1.2 billion prescriptions last
year including close to 100% of
prescriptions from the VA and while you
might be able to buy medicine online you
can't actually download medicine from
the internet to clarify you can download
the medicine Jeremy Renner's collection
of music like noises from the internet
button this is very important you
shouldn't do that
and then there's the potential business
impacts of privatization small
businesses would immediately be affected
if service was reduced like this rock
engraving company in rural Kansas Fisher
Rock is another company that uses the
local post office to ship some of their
smaller products just about every day we
mail out something I hate to see them
lose our post office in in-home shitty
it's handy for businesses like myself
just to run in there and get postage and
and and mail out rocks yeah it would be
a real shame if that business couldn't
mail out its rocks like this one that
says real women heart little wieners or
this one that says the grass is greener
under my wiener I mean that's a perfect
Rock right there if the Postal Service
stopped delivering gutbusters like that
it would be a tragedy although
not for me to be honest since I already
bought mine and I've got to say it's
definitely funnier in person one of the
funniest things about it is how
genuinely heavy this is and look it's
not just small businesses companies like
FedEx and UPS often hand off their
packages to the Postal Service for the
last leg of the delivery especially in
rural areas amazon also contracts many
of its deliveries out
to it and that weirdly enough brings us
to one of the biggest things standing in
the way of the USPS getting the federal
assistance it's so badly needs right now
because this guy has strongly opposed
giving it sufficient aid and many
believe that that's because of its
relationship with Amazon owned of course
by Jeff Bezos who also owns the
Washington Post whose political coverage
is hated by the president who as we know
makes policy decisions based on his
never-ending game of six degrees of how
is this about me
just watch him try and explain why the
Postal Service should not get federal
help the Postal Service is a joke
because they're handing out packages for
Amazon and other internet companies and
every time they bring a package they
lose money on it a post office should
raise the price of a package by
approximately four times because they
don't raise them for some reason these
people have been in there a long time
but for some reason they're very cozy
with some of these companies and they
don't raise the price of a package okay
first the Postal Service is not a joke
it delivers jokes yes and they are as we
know absolutely hilarious but it's not
in itself a joke greener under my wiener
this is the funniest rock of all time
Jesus Christ but second if the Postal
Service quadruples prices on companies
those package delivery costs will almost
certainly be passed on to the consumer
because their companies they don't give
a and third it isn't cutting
sweetheart deals to lose money on every
delivery because in addition to
everything else we've already discussed
that 2006 law made it illegal for the
USPS to price parcel delivery below its
cost so in summation here Trump is
absolutely convinced that the Postal
Service's biggest problem is one of the
few things that he's not actually one of
its problems and that's not just
annoying it's really worrying especially
as just this week he replaced the
outgoing Postmaster General with this
guy Louis to Joy a major Trump donor and
that appointment has worried worried
many many people the Trump may now
able to bend the Postal Service to his
will presumably meaning that by next
year every stamp in America will feature
one of Jeff Bezos his dick pics and the
thing is there are absolutely solutions
that would enable the Postal Service to
help themselves but for all the reasons
that we've discussed their hands are
tied when it comes to pricing on their
main product which may actually help
explain some of their very weird side
hustles for instance you can go on their
website and buy this costume for your
dog which is a great way to make your
dog look like it's performing a postal
themed rendition of dick in a box also a
few years back they entered into a
bizarre partnership with forever21
to unveil a postal service themed
fashion line although as this youtuber
will tell you there were a few issues
with their garments oh my gosh why why
is any of this happening it's like yes I
am the priority my boobs are the price
I'm gonna give it a three and a half out
of ten yeah when you're wearing nothing
but the word priority stretched over
your chest it's a little weird to
realize that the answer to the question
why is any of this happening is at least
in part the postal accountability and
Enhancement Act of 2006 but look
branching out into fashion clearly won't
save the Postal Service that is why it
is so important that they're given much
more flexibility not just on pricing but
also on the types of services they can
offer now experts suggest that the post
offices could expand their services to
issue things like hunting and fishing
licenses and perhaps the best option is
something called postal banking where
the post office doesn't so much act as a
bank as provide some very basic
financial services like savings accounts
and check cashing that wouldn't just
generate revenue it could also help the
estimated 25 percent of people in this
country living in unbanked or
underbanked communities who are often
forced to turn to alternative financial
services like payday lenders which can
charge up to 400% in fees and interest
and this wouldn't be completely out of
the postal services Lane not only did I
already provide some services like
selling money orders money transfers and
prepaid cards but up until the 1960s
they were already doing
it's though 90% of its income is derived
from the sale of stamps the post office
is also the largest Savings Bank in the
country and the largest agency for the
transfer of money it takes you in more
than one-and-a-half million dollars
annually
you know it's depressing that the
weirdest thing about watching old timey
clips now isn't that they're in black
and white or that people are wearing
hats it's that everyone is standing next
to each other in a public place with no
fear of dying honestly at this point I
have such severe quarantine brain I
could wake up in the Jurassic period and
my first thought would be holy
those stegosauruses are standing way too
close together but look postal banking
is clearly more of a long-term solution
it won't get the USPS out of its current
mess what they badly need is an infusion
of funding as soon as possible and not
only should we be demanding that they
get that Congress should also take a
look at undoing some of the more onerous
terms in that 2006 law and until then
there might actually be something small
that we can do here because the purchase
of stamps is still a key revenue
generator for them and and you can
actually get stamps made TV shows have
done this in the past
American Idol sold stamps and veep and
full-frontal recently did giveaways and
while it will not come close to raising
the ninety billion dollars the Postal
Service badly needs we've actually been
working with stamps.com for weeks to not
just do a giveaway but to produce a run
of stamps that are available for you to
buy right now if you go to stamps com
slash last stamp tonight you can find
postage featuring Qi John a Bolivian
zebra mr. Nutter Butter and our personal
favorite and now a stamp you can buy
sheets of these for the next month and I
would really encourage you to do that
they are the perfect way to mail a card
that supports the USPS in its time of
need while also saying I like last week
tonight and I'm sorry I forgot Mother's
Day which you did your piece of if
you liked this segment please buy a
stamp and support the Postal Service if
you hated it buy one anyway and mail me
a letter about how much I suck it's all
the same to them you'd be doing a really
nice thing that's our show thank you so
much for watching
we'll see you next week good night it's
new I know you bye-bye
you're very good interrupting things you
very bad
[Music]